ah
ó
eu queria começar hoje com uma pergunta
que eu tenho certeza que todo mundo aqui
ouviu por volta de 79 vezes ao longo da
vida
qual é o seu sonho foi essa pergunta a
professora da 4ª fé da 4ª série fez pra
gente e tinha que escrever uma redação
sobre isso eu
no auge dos meus 10 anos de idade
eu falei sobre viajar o mundo e tem uma
livraria mas eu também falei uma coisa
bastante inesperada para aquela
professora
eu falei que eu queria ser presidente o
governador ou prefeito porque assim não
conseguiria ter um impacto positivo na
vida das pessoas
para ser honesta desde então essa
vontade entre a política ela foi se
perdendo completamente mas a vontade de
causar impacto positivo nas pessoas
isso se manteve até hoje a pergunta que
ficava na época como é que eu vou fazer
isso né
e na época do vestibular eu li um livro
que me transformou muito é chama
banqueiro dos pobres e é de um cara
chamado bônus e ônus ele ganhou o nobel
da paz porque ele fundou um banco
chamado grameen bank que é um banco de
microcrédito então faz pequenos
empréstimos para pessoas em condições
extremamente vulneráveis começarem o
próprio negócio e assim conseguirem
quebrar o ciclo de pobreza e aquilo me
encantou
eu fiquei abismado como uma coisa que eu
considerava tão pouco dinheiro é cerca
de 40 50 dólares conseguia transformar
de uma forma tão profunda uma família
inteira que eu decidisse da economia por
conta desse livro
já nos primeiros anos da faculdade eu
percebi que eu não queria só lê sobre
essa transformação eu queria vê-la
acontecendo ao vivo então decidir eu vou
pra mim só faltava então basicamente
tudo mesmo
observa se aceita lá e eu tinha visto no
site algumas coisas não tinha nada muito
claro eu fiz pela primeira vez uma coisa
que eu procurei fazer diversas vezes
desde então toda vez eu queria muito uma
coisa fiz uma coisa que algumas pessoas
podem considerar melhor surpreendente
ousada até talvez meio doida também
eu mandei um e mail com o meu currículo
e falando toda minha motivação e
explicando a porque eu queria pra lá e
tudo que eu queria aprender mas também
ajudar
qual não foi minha surpresa quando o
pouco tempo depois eles responderam e
meio me convidando para fazer o estágio
de verão para estrangeiros que eles
tinham cara aquilo foi como se eu
tivesse passado em roberto assim foi um
dos melhores dias da minha vida é e me
marcou demais e é muito interessante é
como uma ferramenta tão simples um e
meio consegue criar uma oportunidade
para a gente a 15 mil quilômetros de
onde a gente mora e aqui eu queria fazer
uma pausa e deixar muito claro que eu
não quero romantizar essa idéia de criar
suas próprias oportunidades
eu vim de uma família de classe média
então eu tive diversas privilégios ao
longo da vida por exemplo pôde estudar
inglês desde pequena o que me permitiu
escrever aquele meio o que eu acredito é
que é possível criar as suas próprias
oportunidades
de acordo com a sua trajetória de acordo
com o seu contexto e aí sim ajudar a
criar oportunidades para outras pessoas
também
então em 2013 eu fui programming que
fica em bangladesh é um país ao lado da
índia e foi um choque
é logo de cara foi o primeiro país
muçulmano que eu visitei então eu tinha
que me acostumar com diversas coisas né
eu tinha que andar constantemente como
tradutor porque nem eu falava a língua
local nem eles falavam inglês
a gente não conseguia se comunicar eu
também tinha que me preocupar bastante
com as roupas que usava em público era
um país muçulmano então eu não queria
fazer qualquer coisa que pudesse deixar
as pessoas desconfortáveis mas mais do
que isso talvez uma das coisas mais
difíceis
é com a qual tive que me acostumar foi a
tomar quatro banhos por dia porque
bangladesh consegue ser mais quente que
cuiabá que é uma renomada capital do
calor no país
e se você escolher assim a coisa que
mais me transformou nessa experiência no
gradim
foi quando a gente pegava os quatro por
quatro e é para o meio do país nos
vilarejos conversar com as mulheres que
tomavam empréstimos do banco o banco
geralmente lista d
ótimo para mulheres porque tinham
percebido que ela tinha uma propensão
maior a usar o dinheiro que elas
começavam a ganhar para retribuir a
própria família então isso teria um
impacto muito maior na sociedade
e aí a gente se perguntava puxa o que
será que passa pela cabeça dessas
mulheres quando elas começam a melhorar
um pouco de condição financeira o que
elas querem fazer com esse dinheiro né
quando foi uma surpresa quando repetidas
vezes é com todas as mulheres que a
gente falando a primeira coisa que elas
falavam é que elas queriam garantir
educação para elas mesmas e pra família
delas para as pessoas ao redor
essa história dessa senhora de verde e
da chefe dela de 15 anos de vermelho
caixa aos 12 anos de idade teve que sair
da escola é pra poder ajudar
financeiramente a família e ela me
contou que o maior sonho dela era poder
voltar a estudar pra terminar de
aprender a ler e escrever
e esse sonho o interessante é que ele
estava virando um sonho palpável a
partir desse momento que a mãe dela
estava começando a melhorar a condição
financeira e essa não era uma história
só dá a deixa a gente ouviu isso de
muitas e muitas e muitas mulheres que a
gente ia conversando e não parei para
pensar cara se eu é se essas mulheres
cria uma oportunidade para elas mesmas
ea primeira coisa que elas pensam em
como criar uma oportunidade pra outras
pessoas geralmente através da educação
se eu trabalhar com educação eu vou ser
uma multiplicadora de oportunidades
então foi isso que decidi fazer eu
voltei para o brasil e na realidade eu
sentia aquele aquela paralisia assim de
alguém que tem um problema grande pela
frente não faço a menor ideia por onde
começar
como falei antes da economia não
entendia tentassem de educação eu tinha
poucas certezas naquela época eu sabia
que eu queria uma coisa que me
desenvolver esse pessoal e
profissionalmente eu sabia que eu queria
ter muita responsabilidade no meu prato
e eu sabia que eu queria ajudar a
construir alguma coisa do zero
só que como tinha muito mais dúvidas do
que certezas naquela época eu voltei
para o fluxo normal de evento da
economia
eu fui trabalhar em uma grande empresa
de bebidas em são paulo
só que esse questionamento se eles nunca
pararam na realidade eles voltaram desde
o primeiro dia que eu comecei a
trabalhar nessa organização e pelo um
ano e meio que eu fiquei lá então eu
tentei
para formas de criar oportunidades eu
comecei a estudar muita coisa é de
educação eu comecei a pesquisar muitas
oportunidades e viu que tinha por aí e
mas mais do que isso comecei a falar com
uma quantidade absurda de gente de
diversas organizações com objetivos
diferentes e valores diferentes para ver
se eu conseguia criar uma oportunidade
para mim mesmo e aí nesse meio de estudo
pesquisa e falar e falar com muitas
pessoas algumas coisas e foi enxergar
algumas coisas que tinham a ver comigo
algumas coisas que não tanto
eu conheci uma pessoa muito importante a
érika e ela estava no início de um
empreendimento que cara me encantou
logo de cara assim era uma oportunidade
que não era 100% garantida
honestamente me deu um super frio na
barriga porque a organização já estava
tinha muito claro para onde eu ia
qualquer crescimento
mas eu senti que era meu próximo passo
então o fuso de cabeça
eu tive a oportunidade de com fundada o
ensino no brasil com um time de pessoas
maravilhoso e isso vem me proporcionando
todas aquelas coisas que eu estava
buscando no início a idéia do ensina é
formar líderes que entendam os desafios
da educação na ponta e então consigam
intervir nesses desafios desde o
terceiro setor até de dentro de uma
empresa ou mesmo de dentro do governo a
gente seleciona pessoas que
reconhecidamente criaram utilizaram as
oportunidades que tiveram ao longo da
vida
eles são jovens talentos de diversas
carreiras e eles passam dois anos como
professores em escolas públicas
localizadas em contextos bastante
vulneráveis
geralmente na periferia de grandes
centros para trabalhar nesses lugares a
gente já teve mas em apenas dois
processos seletivos mais de 12 mil
inscritos quem selecionou apenas 130
jovens incríveis participantes
maravilhosos
a gente pergunta apple quem são essas
pessoas não é quem é a uma pessoa que
toparia o desafio de se entre diversas
coisas a gente procura participantes que
sejam humildes resilientes e focado na
solução dos problemas mas também tem uma
coisa muito
particular que a gente olha a gente que
há pessoas que tenham partido de uma
determinada situação em contexto de vida
e tenham progredido consideravelmente ao
longo da vida criando suas próprias
oportunidades
a idéia então é reconhecer que alguém
por exemplo que passou a vida inteira
tendo que ajudar financeiramente dentro
de casa e mesmo assim mostrou uma
resiliência absurda para não largar os
estudos foi tão empenhado em criar as
suas próprias oportunidades quando
alguém que ter uma educação muito boas
doença excelentes escolas particulares
ao longo da vida mas não se contentou só
com isso e 15 além por exemplo indo
atrás de uma bolsa de estudo superior no
mada em alguma instituição é para de de
ponta né
a idéia aqui é valorizar e perceber
diferentes trajetórias de vida então
perceber que os valores que a gente tem
na nossa organização eles podem ser
vistos de forma diferente em perfis
diferentes de candidatos e foi isso o
que a gente viu no youtube que é um
participante da primeira turma
o yuri eles dão a vida inteira em escola
pública e ele conseguiu entrar numa
excelente universidade do sul do país
o dirigente está em cuiabá leciona
história e no ano passado ele teve uma
aluna tinha muita atenção dele é claro
ela estava no terceiro ano do ensino
médio agora ela percebeu na escola dela
que os alunos
eles tinham uma autoestima muito baixa
então por conta própria ela começou a
desenvolver um projeto chamado
restaurando vidas que buscava empodera
os alunos da escola dela pelas cornetas
os próprios sonhos
o yuri ficou tão encantado com com esse
projeto declara que ele inscreveu a
clara sem ela saber que ela participa de
uma conferência da onu em nova york e
ela foi aceita ela teve a oportunidade
para palestrar contando mais sobre esse
projeto ela estava desenvolvendo e o
bacana é que quando é para voltar para o
brasil ela visitou há gente no nosso
escritório ea gente perguntou para o que
deixou mais animada com essa experiência
e ela respondeu o que mais me anima é
poder voltar pra casa e compartilhar
tudo que eu vivi e aprendi com as
pessoas ao meu redor e foi isso que ela
fez
ela voltou para cuiabá e agora ela virou
uma multiplicadora do projeto
restaurando vidas então ela vai por
diversas escolas públicas de cuiabá com
o mesmo objetivo em poderá os alunos
daquelas escolas para eles correrem
atrás dos próprios sonhos
a nossa organização e essa experiência
me permitir uma transformação
indescritível o que eu mais me orgulho
do que a gente faz é que a gente cria
oportunidades e elas não param por aí
elas são multiplicadas a gente cria
portanto para os ensinos eles queriam
para centenas de outras pessoas e essas
pessoas impactadas não querem parar por
aí elas querem fazer o mesmo e esse é um
círculo virtuoso muito forte
a gente está aqui hoje é porque a gente
tem essa urgência por ouvir e
compartilhar histórias que ajudem a
transformar a nós mesmos ea nossa
sociedade e não necessariamente é só
através da educação tem diversas formas
é que a gente consegue fazer isso desde
poxa ajudar alguém a treinar para uma
entrevista de emprego que a pessoa que é
muito pensar em políticas de diversidade
dentro da organização onde a gente
trabalha ou mesmo trabalhar de dentro do
governo pensando em políticas públicas
mais inclusivas
imagina se cada um de nós aqui tomasse
proveito das oportunidades que a gente
teve ao longo da vida
para potencializar as pessoas ao nosso
redor
imagina se isso fosse feito pelos quatro
cantos do país
eu não tenho dúvidas que a gente viver
num país muito mais justo e muito mais
igualitário e esse é um círculo virtuoso
muito difícil de se quebrar
então acho que a pergunta que fica é o
que você vai fazer por este círculo
virtuoso se ampliar ainda mais
obrigada
[Aplausos]